wir stellen fest es sind sehr turbulente
tage für die europäische union erdogan
und braig sind heißen unsere großen
baustellen und immerhin in sachen
brachse zeichnet sich seit gestern
vorgestern etwas ab womit ich zu meinen
lebzeiten nicht mehr gerechnet habe es
gibt einen deal die briten ziehen
endlich aus
nach über drei jahren dreckiger
scheidungen packen sie ihre sachen und
der rest von europa kann sich wieder mit
echten problemen beschäftigen jetzt wird
alles gut
juni wieder porridge ich behaupte ich
behaupte mit diesem deal kann überhaupt
nichts mehr anbrennen
es ist extrem extrem unwahrscheinlich
dass boris johnson diesen deal am
samstag hier hinter mir durch unterhaus
bringt ich kann nicht mehr ich will auch
nicht mehr ehrlich jetzt und dann geht
alles wieder von vorne los
fristverlängerung neuwahlen oder mein
gott wir sind gefangen in einer
verdammten zeitschleife und ich habe das
gefühl so claude juncker von der eu noch
chef da geht es genau so kurz vor der
rente klingt der mann als hätte er jetzt
aber wirklich die schnauze voll
er übernahm ost angespannten über die
distanz lincoln jeder versteht englisch
aber niemand versteht england irgendwo
in diesem hässlichen gebäude hier wird
gerade darüber verhandelt
als big gegen
was mit ihm los
ja hinter juncker steht jetzt auf sicher
immer so ein typ mit dem
betäubungsgewehr einfach nur weil sie
angst vor ihm haben und ich verstehe
sein frust ich verstehe den frust
wirklich denn überlegen sie mal selbst
wenn dieser deal überraschend durch geht
bleiben ohne ende offene fragen meine
ausgerechnet die engländer sollen dann
für die eu bei der sie nicht mehr
mitmachen wollen
dollar eintreiben soll das denn gehen
ist er nicht die wollen uns doch als
steueroase demnächst konkurrenz machen
und vor allem boris johnson darf man nie
trauen diesen notorischen lügner
vielleicht will ja sogar dass das ding
morgen noch scheitert und haben sie das
gesehen wie der die arme queen diese
woche gezwungen hat im unterhaus eine
von ihm geschriebene wahlkampfrede
vorzutragen gibt da so fröhlich los aber
schön alles vorlesen und stelle ich dir
batterien die heizung ab das ist die
königin muss seine rede der wort für
wort vorlesen wahlkampf andererseits
vielleicht ist das auch ein ganz neues
geschäftsmodell selbst die fein royals
müssen ja demnächst sehen wo sie
finanziell bleiben
royaler glanz für alle mit rente queen
ihre texte vorgelesen von königin
elizabeth zum beispiel wenn ihr onkel
günther geburtstag hat kaum zu glauben
aber wahr
der winter wird heute 80 jahre
als hörbuch für ihre kinder handelte
tiger der kleine bär und der kleine kita
lebten in einem gemütlichen haus unten
am fluss die green macht sogar für sie
schluss der gieseler
jetzt sitzen neben gisela es liegt nicht
an dir es liegt an mir ich hasse dich
und bums die nachbarin
sie ist viel billiger als sie denken
[Applaus]
auch kindergeburtstage oder baumarkt
eröffnung die praxistage eine telenovela
die keine sau mehr sehen will die aber
nie abgesetzt wird so aber die ohnmacht
der eu zeigt sich in einem anderen fall
ja noch viel grausamer ich sage nur
erdogan seine truppen greifen in syrien
die kurden an und dann nennt er das
ganze auch noch operation friedens
quelle zynischer geht es ja wohl gar
nicht
als nächstes will er wahrscheinlich noch
den friedensnobelpreis es kann doch
alles nicht wahr sein wirklich ja
nur auf druck der usa gibt es jetzt eine
waffenruhe die wahl offensichtlich
keinen tag hält die außenminister
unseren euro unserer europäischen union
konnten sich trotzdem nicht mal darauf
einigen mit sanktionen gegen die türkei
auch nur zu drohen
wir drohen nicht mal der erde hat sich
doch kaputt in europa ja lacht sich
kaputt und das merkt man sogar wenn man
wie ich kein wort türkisch versteht
[Musik]
europa filme oder oder was heißt das auf
deutsch
hey europa pass auf ich sage es noch
einmal wenn ihr unsere operation als
invasion kritisiert dann werden wir ganz
einfach unsere türen öffnen und 3,6
millionen flüchtlinge schicken so befehl
man sollte haben wir nie wieder invasion
jetzt schreibt uns dieser diktator schon
unsere wortwahl vor
übrigens mit erfolg die bundesregierung
spricht offiziell nur noch von einer
militär operation erdogan und sein
botschafter in berlin drohen uns mit
flüchtlingen wie ernst meint er dass
zuerst ist das keine drohung sondern
eine warnung ach so ach so dann bin ich
erleichtert ja die eu ist erpressbar
weil wir seit jahren keine gemeinsame
flüchtlings und außenpolitik hinkriegen
dann könnte man erdogan mit
wirtschaftssanktionen wenn man wollte
hart treffen auch deutschland im herzen
ist der typ doch auch nur ein kleiner
vorstadt gangster ja der der noch
reicher werden will ja noch reicher
werden will
jetzt erlebt der es seinetwegen ein
comeback assad und putin freuen sich
eine eine völlig irre weltlage bei der
man mit der geografie schnell
durcheinander kommt wie klar waren die
äußerungen aus deutschland bei dem
völkerrechts bruch russlands auf der
krim
wir sehen jetzt in thüringen dasselbe
nämlich eine völkerrechtswidrige
invasion
einer islamistischen präsidialdemokratie
jahren dazu
dazu muss man sagen thüringen syrien
wird oft verwechselt ja wegen und
natürlich wegen der syrien bratwurst so
leider leider hat die eu diese woche
eben kein waffenembargo gegen die türkei
verlangt oder verhängt stattdessen
verkündet heiko maas lediglich keine
neuen rüstungsdeals mehr zu genehmigen
mit der türkei tatsächlich war die
türkei letztes jahr der größte abnehmer
deutscher waffen unser top kunde einmal
mehr wird unsere außenpolitik irgendwie
ja konzeptlos reden wir also mal über
heiko maas für ihn sprechen genau zwei
sachen erstens erdogan hat ihnen diese
woche haben sie mitgekriegt beschimpft
was immer ein gutes zeichen ist und maas
hat im ausnahmen natürlich das muss man
sagen einen völlig neuen stil und nicht
zu sagen style geprägt den auch seine
mitarbeiter imitieren holger stockhaus
zum beispiel er leitet dort die
pressestelle heißt doch herr stockhaus
ich hatte nur gerade mein eigenes bild
im monitor
herbig ich weiß doch ganz genau was
jetzt wieder kommt heiko maas hat keine
linie in der außenpolitik wo ist die
deutsche strategie
fakt ist wir hatten überhaupt noch nie
ein außenminister der pünktlich zum welt
café tag genau das richtige twittert
hier offizieller tweet unseres hauses
geil oder ja also solche fotos konnte
man mit gabriel nie machen ja so ein
weitwinkel gibt's gar nicht
und darüber steht eine tasse kaffee kann
vieles sein
auf auslandsreisen von heiko maas ist
sie oft eine insel der ruhe zwischen
terminen heiko maas das geheimnis ist
seine bekömmlichkeit ach ja sicher aber
sagen sie blamieren wir uns nicht gerade
total in der syrien frage verzeihung
deutschlands rolle ist doch klar
definiert wir haben es zur kunstform
erhoben bei konflikten an der
seitenlinie zu stehen und den anderen zu
sagen was sie jetzt tun müssten also
nicht wie die wir legen derweil
sorgenvoll die stirn in falten und
klimpern noch sorgenvoller mit den augen
wir haben innerhalb der bundesregierung
entschieden das ist eine weitere
rüstungsexporte mehr in die türkei geben
wir gegangen und übrigen seit der
militäroffensive der türkei nach wien
schon vor einiger zeit keine
rüstungsgüter mehr in die türkei
geliefert
neu beim wdr
die sendung mit dem mars klar im
nachhinein hätten wir den kunden unsere
deutschen es kämpfer lieber abnehmen
sollen jetzt sind die wohl abgehauen ist
blöd wenn die kunden am telefon waren
haben wir immer so getan als wäre die
verbindung schlechte ist rauscht
satirisch ich lege jetzt auf kühle gülle
es ist so erbärmlich wir deutschen haben
wir immer gesagt die amis soll mal
aufhören weltpolizei zu spielen und
jetzt sagen die amis können euch einfach
aufhören weltpolizei zu spielen ja
können sie ja auch nicht so fällt doch
auf dass wir gar nichts tun ist voll und
kollegial
außerdem was sollen wir denn machen als
bundesregierung sanktionen gegen die
türkei klingt immer gut aber so was
erlauben uns siemens und daimler ja gar
nicht außenpolitik ist halt komplex
meine abteilung zum beispiel ist
eigentlich voll ausgelastet mit dem
instagram account vom heiko jeder
einfach in new york so über die straße
wie einer von uns nur schöner hier
feierte noch an einer rede
und hier ist er einfach nur heiko maas
guckt so rechts aus dem bild ich vermute
der hängten spiegelt
heiko maas alfermann checker kaffee
trinken kann
wo ist eigentlich mein fotograf hallo
holger stockhaus meine damen und herren
michael de schreibt auf facebook wilke
du bist der letzte arsch nur große
fresse ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es
hart auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir
in die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 im zweiten oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren